j'arrive j'avais rendez vous à 15h 15
rendez vous qui était programmé depuis
une quinzaine de jours
et là j'apprends arrivés sur place que
il ya plus de doses je n'ai plus de
doses pour me faire vacciner quoi c'est
un petit peu contradictoire on nous
demande de faire un donc l'effort de la
de se faire vacciner le plus vite
possible et on s'aperçoit que ben yahia
pas les doses nécessaires pour vacciner
ceux qui veulent le faire quoi arriver à
cette étape de cette pandémie en fait on
devrait pas avoir le droit de manquer de
l'ours quoi c'est nos deux flacons de
baudart doc on a réussi à voir très
difficilement ce flacon là il est un
médecin
ce flacon là il est un pharmacien mais
nous nous n'avons pas reçu nos doses de
vaccin pour que nous avons commandé il
ya maintenant treize jours depuis le
début de la crise ça a été ça en fait un
tiers
les annonces et après ce qui se passe
sur le terrain nous on veut des doses on
nous dit qu'il y à des doses mais sur le
terrain en fait on a de grosses
difficultés à s'approvisionner
[Musique]